bueno estas horas ya hay celebraciones
en todo el país en los partidores del
rechazo y también en varias partes de
santiago en la parte en los barrios más
adinerados de la capital chilena se está
celebrando está este resultado bastante
bastante con un amplio margen de votos
de diferencia algo que no era para nada
esperado del otro lado todos los los
voceros del comando de la prueba
reconocieron la derrota dijeron hacerlo
desde un lugar muy humilde mientras que
el presidente del abriel boris ya
encabezó un comité político en la moneda
y convocó a todos los partidos políticos
para desde ya mismo iniciar la
continuidad de este proceso constitutivo
en la gran incógnita es cómo se va a
llevar adelante cómo se va a encauzar
este proceso tras este impactante
resultado de las urnas que se han
manifestado muy claramente contra esa
nueva propuesta de texto constitucional
en aproximadamente 15 minutos se espera
el discurso del presidente gabriel boric
mira a la nación ella ha afirmado que
era un día para estar orgullosos y
también que iba a convocar a la unidad
nacional pasara lo que pasara para
seguir continuando en un camino que
permita una mayor igualdad para todos y
avanzar y crecer económicamente veremos
qué es lo que dice un discurso muy
esperado para ver cuáles van a ser las
líneas en las que se va a mover este
proceso de cambios esperado ansiado
solicitado también en las calles que
sufre con este resultado electoral un
revés en el día de hoy patricia o en un
poco nos adelantaba recién que sigue a
partir de ahora pero bueno estos días ya
se estaba evaluando no ya prácticamente
era un hecho no sólo por los sondeos
sino también por el clima social la
información que nos venía stand y que
veníamos recibiendo este triunfo del
rechazo o no y nos comentábamos también
que tanto desde el oficialismo como
desde la oposición ya venían planteando
este escenario y nuevas propuestas
teniendo en cuenta no que suceda esto
que finalmente ocurrió en este contexto
teniendo esto en cuenta que sigue a
partir de ahora de mañana lunes
seguramente
así es lo que sí que ha sido positivo en
la manifestación de varios partidos de
la derecha que han manifestado estar
comprometidos con el proceso
constitutivo con ese nuevo proceso de
cambios desde otro lugar ya han sido
varios líderes de algunos de los
partidos de derechas que han se han
manifestado en esa dirección y por
supuesto el congreso ya había modificado
el oscuro incluso para reformar la
actual constitución la constitución de
augusto pinochet pero también se abre
ahora el proceso un nuevo proceso de
parte de todos los actores que sí están
comprometidos con este cambio